I want to see a gun free world and an
actual I want in the environmental
friendly world because we haven't been
so nice to the environment
it's like saying you're not cleaning up
your room right like sometimes I don't
like cleaning up my room or when I have
friends over I had to clean up a lot
after them so basically what we're doing
in that environment we're basically
putting all this stuff in our room and
in the room is our environment and we're
putting all these like bottles and all
this stuff and we don't clean up after
it we just leave it and it damages it
and it kind of you just kind of get like
your room once you like don't clean them
up and it starts smelling and sometimes
because like dirty clothes are thrown
everywhere things just start getting
dirtier and that's what's happening to
the environment now I want to help
change the world and make the world a
better place we have to see your world
as important to my world and my issue
and so it would be so beautiful if we
would understand that you know those
that are suffering those that are being
that are marginalized in our nation
that's my issue that's part of my
responsibility as a citizen to care
about the least of these to care about
others to care about what's going on in
their world we can no longer just turn
away we have to get involved and all of
us have to see ourselves as responsible
citizens I'm inspired by what I see
young people doing I give a couple
examples I'm inspired by things that
I've seen black lives matter do I'm
inspired by the me to movement I'm
inspired by the Parkland students and
I'm inspired by young people like Greta
Thornburg who we all should be inspired
by whether we agree with her or not it's
interesting that young people are
leading us today when I was young I was
hoping to one day become a leader maybe
and I have not seen the engagement that
I see by students like the Parkland
students who are
high school students at the time the
incidents occurred in parkland I've not
seen that since 1963 when students went
to jail in Birmingham and helped to
desegregate that city in 1963 over 3,000
students were arrested
so the Parkland removed met reminds me
of that at another level and I think
that as young people become engaged in
terms of politics I think we'll see a
different political discourse so I'm
inspired by that